inauguration et ouverture à paris du
salon de l'agriculture et le président
jacques chirac habitués fidèles de la
manifestation était bien sûr au rendez
vous des éleveurs et de leurs
préoccupations
le reportage de claude guillaneau et
jean jacques botti un bain de foule de
deux heures et demie jacques chirac n'a
certainement rien vu du salon de
l'agriculture pas plus les vaches
limousines que les charolaises mais
super serré beaucoup de mains des
milliers de mains dans une joyeuse
bousculade
les feuilletons chaîne plus de mains
possibles vous avez vu le président hu y
ait cet exercice laborieux pour le
président de la république a fait
beaucoup d'heureux et d'heureuses chacun
attendait son tour avec impatience
il est vrai que depuis son passage au
ministère de l'agriculture entre 1972 et
jacques chirac s'est fait beaucoup
d'amis dans le monde paysan chiraquien
de toujours quelqu'un pour vous demander
aux autres je connais vous mais moi je
suis toujours là déçu non non non non on
y croit encore car le travail du
président c'est aussi de goûter les
produits régionaux
impossible de refuser sous peine de
froisser son public maison consacrant sa
visite essentiellement à l'élevage bovin
le président de la république a aussi
tenu à manifester sa préoccupation pour
cette activité toujours très éprouvé par
la crise de la vache folle
ah oui on faire entre 1000 et 2000
francs fou
vaste de réforme est justement en
mettant l'accent sur la qualité de la
viande
le salon de l'agriculture veut tout
faire pour rassurer les consommateurs